Andrés Buenas tardes existen posiciones
encontradas por un lado se le critica a
la presidenta boluarte de demorarse en
establecer el principio de autoridad y
dejar que las protestas se incrementen
en todo el Perú mientras que otros
señalan que establecer el estado de
emergencia nacional por 30 días implica
suspender derechos constitucionales como
la inviolabilidad de domicilio la
libertad de tránsito la libertad de
reunión y la seguridad personal y eso
también significa alterar la Navidad
para más de 33 millones de peruanos por
culpa de miles de manifestantes por otro
lado se espera que esta noche la
presidenta Dina boluarte declare la
instalación de un toque de queda en el
país para controlar los desmanes
Mientras tanto la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas ha mostrado su
preocupación por la situación que vive
Perú en este momento y se ha hecho un
llamado y recomendación a conservar el
estado de derecho y dejar las vías para
que los peruanos puedan expresar su voz
y también manifestarse Pero siempre y
cuando esto sea de manera pacífica
Francisco hablemos ahora de Pedro
Castillo Qué probabilidades tiene el ex
mandatario de librarse del pedido de
prisión preventiva mañana
la verdad que existe muy pocas
posibilidades porque Pedro Castillo
tiene una situación muy difícil ya que
existen pruebas que lo implican
seriamente en delitos de rebelión
conspiración y abuso de autoridad al
disponer la disolución del congreso del
pasado 7 de diciembre
hemos recibido información por fuentes
de la fiscalía que la fiscal general de
Perú Patricia benavídez le ofreció a
Pedro Castillo acogerse Al beneficio de
testigo protegido siempre y cuando
delate a los participantes de esta
conspiración pero que ha sido rechazó y
mañana el juez Juan Carlos checkley
decidirá lo que todos ya hablan de los
18 meses de prisión preventiva contra
Pedro Castillo